boa tarde galera que primeiramente
agradecer à organização aqui do detex
indaiatuba lucas é uma ou outra aqui
cantando para vocês
então eu preparei duas músicas para
contar pra vocês eu espero que vocês
gostem
lembro que teve que caminhar já vi um
brilho no olhar e junto com sorriso céu
o teu olhar vem de encontro ao meu meu
dia se fez mais feliz
mesmo sem você perto de mim
mesmo longe de mim eu fico o tempo todo
a imaginar o que fazer quando te
encontrar
mas se eu fizer o que vai dizer
será que é capaz de entender
mesmo se não for eu vou tentar vou fazer
você minutar por isso vim aqui te dizer
me namora pois quando só eu sei que você
chora e fica em casa só contando as
horas reclama só do tempo que demora
abre os braços vem me namora eu quero dá
vazão ao sentimento mostrar que lindo
que eu sinto por dentro
beleza é essa que eu te canto agora abre
os braços vem me namora
ah
pensa está vivendo mais jô sem saber se
me quero não
quem dera se a resposta fosse sim mas
acho que já nem liga pra mim se for
assim o meu coração sofre só assim você
bate mais triste em mas ele ainda pode
se alegrar
se de repente você reparar que com você
também aconteceu que sente amor tão
grande quanto meu
abra os olhos e veja quem te adora e
sonha com você no mundo afora e volta só
pra te dizer é a menina mora pois quando
só eu sei que você chora e fica em casa
só contando as horas e como só do tempo
que demora abre os braços vem me namora
ah
obrigada gente é pra quem não sabe essa
música chama me namora e ao próximo como
cantar chama pisando descalço
não sei se vocês conhecem é da banda eva
então espero fazê-lo assim de novo
pisando descalço neste chão molhado
dentro do teu lado para relaxar fazendo
fogueiras sem eira nem beira deitado na
esteira vendo o a pego meu violão canta
uma canção que já fez no psi por a dança
aquele dom se que deve emitir no
desembaraço desse meu cantá lá morena de
sair a pequena com os olhos transparece
hoje na natureza não importa feira é dia
de torcer e não de trabalhar não importa
ser é dia de ver e não de trabalhar
não importa feira dia de doer e não de
trabalhar eu brinco pelo espaço
estreitando laços e ano tenho fotos para
carregar minha vida plena não faço
besteira peça padroeira prometeu soar
escuta o meu coração olhos minha razão
muitas vezes atrapalha o meu pensar
ele me trouxe o desenvolvimento justo no
momento em que eu tenho
sem pará sai do dilema e transporta duro
e olhar paredes prefiro está hoje na
natureza não importa feira é dia de
derenne onde trabalhar
não importa ter edinho de doer e não de
trabalhar não importa pêra dia de
governo de trabalhar muito obrigada